I think we can all agree that mother's
days a fake holiday created by lazy moms
who want a day off sure some moms
deserve it but most do not and who
better to determine whether you're a
good mama or a bad mama than me a man
first mama
all right yeah love yeah okay we'll talk
more
[Music]
mom hopefully he's still on her
insurance so is that mama good or bad
first of all she rear-ended her son
second of all she let her son own a
motorcycle third she raised a potty
mouth this is a textbook bad mama on to
the next mama
[Music]
on a scooter saving the environment plus
she's got amazing reflexes she
sacrificed her own body for her child
again kid never even touched the ground
that's a good mama hit me with the next
mama
oh why don't you really teach that
driver a lesson smash your baby through
his windshield she's awfully high and
mighty for someone who's just abandoned
their child in the middle of the
intersection that's a bad mama enough
drama
give me a mama he should never slip and
slide in the house and it's especially
dangerous in a tiny house that's a bad
mama I need Moe mama she's perpetuating
a culture of sexism an outdated gender
roles by using that language on the
other hand her son as being a huge
that's a good mama
happy Mother's Day too only the good
Mama's out there
you